what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to my
honest
experience of being on fresh and fit by
rebecca
uh barrett before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
okay let's hey guys welcome back to my
channel if you're new here
my name is rebecca and today i'm going
to be sharing with you guys
my experience from the freshman fit
podcast
so if you haven't known or you just
finding out right now
i was on the freshman fit podcast on a
thursday
i will link that video up above and
below for you guys to check out
but a lot of you have been asking me
what that experience was
like what the behind the scenes are how
the guys are
so i wanted to share this video while
this was all still fresh in my head
and while i could still remember but
before i get started i wanted to share
with you guys some life updates
my husband and i are moving this week so
while you're watching this video i'm in
the process of moving
and that means that my video on
friday will be a video from my friend
shisha zed i'm going to be sharing that
video that he recorded on his channel on
here i think it's an important
conversation that i want to
spread on this channel as well and get
more attention and views on
so i'm going to be sharing that and then
next monday i will be
back hopefully in a new setup as you
guys will see that i'm in a new
apartment
we are excited to move and grow into a
bigger space i hope you guys are excited
for
some of my new videos that will be
coming out soon but yeah without further
ado
let's get into this video okay i love
her style
actually she's like so classically
pretty oh my gosh she's so pretty all
right
so many of you have been asking me
what it was like to be on the fresh and
fit podcast
and to be completely honest it was a
pretty good experience
i don't really have anything negative to
say
about this experience
damn it i just knocked over my guitar
or about the guys but i really wanted to
walk you through
my day leading up to the show and even
on the show and some of my
thoughts post show so i filmed with them
on thursday and for some of you who
don't know
they filmed the after hour show pretty
late
they start their live stream at about
10 45 to 11 and so it's a
long build up to get to the actual
time that you're filming leading up i
was
just preparing myself mentally and
physically all day
as many of you know i am pregnant so
you know it takes a lot of it takes a
huge toll on your body so i'm
always tired i'm out of breath all the
time as you guys can probably start
telling from my videos
so i really wanted to rest up that day i
wanted to relax
i wanted to relax my brain but
you know you kind of have 11 at night
they're usually like three hours
long right some anxiety because honestly
i didn't know what could happen from
that day i didn't know if i was gonna be
on a show with
some you know crazy girls or if it was
going to be a chill show
or if i would have to like prepare
myself
like any other way i really didn't know
what to think ahead of time
i feel like they wing it with the girls
as well so i don't know if they
know what kind of girls are going to be
on there that particular day
you know it's a little bit nerve-racking
i
definitely was in prayer a lot i
like to pray and ask god for guidance
and giving me the
right words to say and just spreading
a positive message because that's what i
do
i try to spread as much of a positive
message as i possibly can on this
channel
and to you guys so i wanted to be in a
positive state of mind i wanted to be
balanced and just calm before walking
into a situation where i
really didn't know what was gonna go
down i had to
get there at around 9 30ish
to do the pre-show and then do sound
check and stuff
so i live in west palm and i had to
drive all the way to miami so
that was an hour drive to get there
it's not as bad as you know flying in
or anything like that but i drove from
west palm to miami so i had to leave an
hour early
i ate dinner i felt prepared i felt
calm and then i got there and
my anxiety started going up because
again you
don't really know what's going to happen
i i got so nervous being on kevin samuel
show because
it's like you just think of the worst
thing that can happen so if you say the
wrong thing you're going to end up
like going viral or you know clipping
you the wrong way
oh my gosh watched the shows leading up
to the day that i was going to be there
and three or two of the
three that i watched were like crazy
crazy and he had to frank castle a bunch
of girls
so that's what i was expecting i was
expecting to walk in
and see a whole bunch of girls and
it was not the situation at all so
my husband and i arrived there we meet
chris downstairs
with the other girls they check us in
and we go
up to the actual studio apartment
and we you know we get settled in
we sign papers and stuff like that we're
exploring
the studio we got to take pictures and
do videos and
chris was also doing some promo stuff
and then fresh got there as well
and he was hanging out and talking to
people
and then we did sound check which
they do like a good sound check like
they get all of our mark
mics ready they get our headphones ready
so they wanted to make sure everything
was good and that our voices were clear
and stuff like that so
that was all fine and my husband
okay in turn you guys already know on
this channel i have such a problem
with mics i swear this mic is good like
it's literally like every person
that i've told the brand of this mic
they always tell me oh wow that's such a
good mic
i just literally i'm so bad with the
tech stuff it's harder than you think
got to be there they were so
respectful to my husband and
respectful to me they shook our hands
they you know they were excited for the
show
and so it was an overall good experience
for him as well
he got to watch the show from the back
side of it which was kind of cool like
he was watching it from
the angle that chris and trey sit at so
it was really cool to have him there
supporting me
because it is very nerve-wracking you
really don't know what to expect
so then myron shows up and then we do
the whole
um getting the instagrams getting all of
the social media stuff
ready for the live stream and then we
recorded we were live
and it was really cool to see all of you
guys in the chat
ahead of time and sending your guys a
super chat i thought that was awesome
they said so many people were there to
see me and even the girls were like
who are you like can i follow you on
youtube or something because there are
all these people are here to see you
i think some of the girls were already
on their toes before
we even sat down and got to record
and i think that's probably why the
trajectory of the show
went a little bit different and honestly
for my first show in my first visit on
the podcast
it was truly a good experience
overall the girls were super sweet the
girls that were sitting
next to me shay and sunny were so sweet
we're
chatting ahead of time and we were all
just laughing ahead of time so
already i felt a sense and that's the
thing um
a lot of times they'll kind of like pit
you like you know it's us versus them
and by us i mean
like girls that don't you know live a
certain type of lifestyle but a lot of
times like
girls get along in general at least a
lot of the more laid-back girls like me
i don't know even if girls like live
super differently i don't care like i'll
still be
friendly whatever it's at ease walking
into it because
i know how women are and sometimes it
can be very catty just right off the
jump
damn so already i was
relaxed and calm and knowing that it was
going to be a good show and hopefully
a positive show and that's exactly what
it ended up being
i really felt myron and fresh just
relaxed
rebecca i don't like what you're saying
that's miss cendrick that's super
i like all like not all guys are like
that
not all guys not all successful guys not
all men not
all women please don't just want to see
what you felt like it wouldn't feel like
to be minor games for two seconds
no i came i came prepared for the
i came prepared okay but it's it's it's
honestly true they were laughing
and having a good time and it wasn't
such a
serious show even though we were talking
about serious topics
it wasn't so much that combativeness
that happens to the show
and that is what's entertaining about
the show is
the fights and the back and forth
between myron and the girls
but i honestly think for my first time
on the podcast
that it went exactly how i wanted it to
go
it was more of an educational segment
than it was
this contention of going back and forth
and i really think the girls
understood where i was coming from and
they agreed with a lot of the things
again a lot of them were very young 22
to 26.
i could already tell from the jump that
they weren't going to be pushing back a
lot
just because of my background and
how i approached them and how the
conversations were approached
yeah and your mindset with things
changes a lot from
i mean i would say mine started to shift
when i was about 21.
i'm 24 now but i don't know at a certain
age
i think girls start to become more
realistic and
understand like what works in a marriage
some girls never learn
but like the older you get sometimes the
wiser you get
so they were definitely one of the most
open-minded group of people
of women that were on the panel that
could have been on the panel
now to be honest i wish that there were
more questions being asked
to me or to the group i think that we
could have had a longer conversation
it was a shorter show and
i wish we had more time to talk about
different
topics and discuss
more things but to be honest i was
already
super tired and it was way past my
bedtime
so it was almost nice that it ended in
in that way and in that time
frame i could tell that the girls were
listening to what i was saying
and that myron mostly myron and i could
have
a actual like intellectual conversation
and i think that a lot of the walls and
the barriers came down
in this episode and i really appreciate
that because
that's what i wanted to accomplish from
the beginning
i was expecting to get stuff thrown at
me
or fights to happen but i'm glad that it
happened
this way this is a long-winded way to
say that
overall the show was amazing i would
love to be invited back i would love to
have
more discussions around marriage
relationships
even the whole feminist movement talking
to
other women that are really into the
ideology
and i'm bringing her on the channel soon
we haven't set up a date yet
but i swear to have more conversations
open dialogue about this and i hope i
get invited back
rebecca you're invited to my channel
come up
pull pull up um i love her like she's
actually one of my favorite new channels
that i listen to
like i literally love her but yeah i
think
is like you guys know i have mixed
feelings about them like i think they're
definitely like fake it till you make it
type of guys
um but i definitely appreciate their
work ethic and i don't
you know i don't think they're creepy in
any way i know there's some stuff going
around about them but let me know what
you guys think in the comments don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell
and i'll talk to you guys next time